at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking I'm a cybernetic organism living
tissue over metal endoskeleton this
episode is brought to you by me undies
if I'm not going commando I'm in my
undies I have been testing these
underwear for three to four months now
pretty much every day and in fact
throughout a bunch of my other underwear
this morning and on the road in the
house they are extremely comfortable
they look good feel good they are made
of micro Modell 2 times softer than
cotton as scientifically tested using
the cob bottom method sounds very fancy
of course and I get a lot of compliments
from the ladies for these you don't get
diaper but you don't get the tired
elastic band they look great and they
have underwear for both men and women
check out my undies com forward slash
Tim and you can see everything I've been
wearing they're ridiculous the sublime
everything in between including my
favorite which is called out and I would
be remiss if I didn't mention there
lounge pants this is a new thing and
I've been wearing their lounge pants
when I record podcasts I've been wearing
them out and about when I'm walking the
dog meeting people for coffee and they
are extremely comfortable they're made
from the same material as the underwear
but some of them like the blue ones I
have have pockets so you can walk about
without seeming like you're off of your
meds and completely crazy so that is
awesome
and if you're not happy with the first
pair you try on I assume that refers to
the underwear they'll refund you
completely and you can keep the pair you
tried on for free but if you're that
kind of person you should be ashamed
because that's disgusting me Andy's com4
slash Tim check it out
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealthfront is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show is because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealth front that I've invested a say
sniffing an amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
that account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront dot-com
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
now I do have to read a mandatory
disclaimer wealthfront Inc is an SEC
registered investment advisor investing
in securities involves risks and there
is the possibility of losing money past
performance is no guarantee of future
results please visit wealth front comm
to read their full disclosure so check
it out guys this is one of the hottest
most innovative companies coming out of
Silicon Valley and they're killing it
they've become massively popular just
take a look see what portfolio they
would create for you and you can use
that information however you want
wealthfront comm forward slash tim hello
ladies and germs this is Tim Ferriss
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show I'm sitting in the darkness
on Long Island I don't know why all my
lights are out but it is very moody in
here and that's not really appropriate
to the episode you're gonna listen to
which is a very fun very funny episode
with Rainn Wilson who is best known for
playing Dwight on NBC's Emmy winning the
office you can say hello to him on
Twitter please do at Rainn Wilson Rai n
n WI LSO n he's also acted in super
cooties Juno monsters vs. aliens
the rocker and many other movies he
co-founded soul pancake I didn't know
this before doing my homework for this
interview and I love soul pancake it is
a media company that seeks to tackle
life's big questions they put out some
amazing videos including some massive
mega hits like kid president he's a
board member of moto foundation and
co-founded lead a an educational
initiative in rural Haiti that we'll
talk about instead of it he's also has
but not least voice cracking like Doogie
Howser excuse me the author of a brand
new book the bassoon King which is
hilarious and very insightful it is it
is his laugh-out-loud memoir we cover a
lot in SEPA soda I won't go through
everything because that would be
ridiculous but here are a few the value
of as if exercises from drama school his
meditation practices we talk and compare
different methods the origins of soul
pancake and some of their mega hits
favorite books documentaries and movies
acting it's therapy even for not actors
the sexy nostril exercise and much more
so thank you for listening as always and
without further ado please enjoy my
conversation with Rainn Wilson
Rainn welcome to the show hey Tim
Farriss good to be on your show I have
been looking forward to this and it's
just before Thanksgiving
which is this was appropriate you've put
out a lot of good work in the world so
thank you for that I'll begin with that
I appreciate it and I observe sort of
the canon of work thus far and you've
spanned across multiple types of media
when you meet people and they ask you
the question what do you do how do you
typically answer that well it's a little
easier for me than it is for someone
like you I mean I do a lot of different
things but my first answer is I'm an
actor cuz that's where I started that's
my greatest love that's where I hope to
be spending my dying breath I'd love to
be playing King Lear on the stage
somewhere and Keeling over when I'm 87
years old so I'm an actor I'm also an
entrepreneur I like to think of myself
as a writer and a humanitarian as well
so throw those in for the mix into the
mix how did could you describe for
people who aren't familiar with it soul
pancake because I love soul pancake and
have been a consumer and I guess more
recently a participant had an excerpt
from an interview that I did turned in
animation and put on SoulPancake which
was extremely oh that's right
humbling and flattering but what it what
it means to be wealthy I guess or
defining that term could you tell people
a bit about soul pancake for those who
aren't familiar sure so when I started
getting well known for being Dwight on
the office I saw an incredible
opportunity to do something distinct you
positive on the web the web at that time
when we were first having these
conversations in like 2008 was just the
worst of humanity just everything it was
just pop-up ads and porn and just
crassness and chat rooms and nowadays
it's actually there's a lot more
positive and there's interesting stuff
on the web but back then not so much I
wanted a a forum for place for for
people to be able to discuss what I call
life's big questions that's something
that's always really intrigued me what
it means to be a human being and all of
the questions around that those are
scientific questions they're
philosophical questions they're
spiritual questions they're questions of
art and creativity it's what it means to
be alive where there was no place on the
web to kind of discuss that stuff so we
started as a kind of a blog slash social
networking site where we had posts and
people could write in their own life's
big questions create member names and
interact with each other and it was
really cool for a while then we started
making some video content on the side
just as a side thing I had done Oprah's
podcast and I started doing some stuff
with the Oprah Winfrey Network and
making some little videos we started a
YouTube channel and all of a sudden we
saw wait a second we're way better at
making videos and we are making like web
technology for interaction between
people so we kind of ditched the whole
web we in fact we did we ditched our
website we pivoted completely and we
became a media company so SoulPancake is
a media company we put out digital
content across multiple platforms
through the social networks through
YouTube we do stuff on television we do
stuff for brands and advertising and
it's also changed a little bit in that
now our mission is to produce inspiring
content about stuff that matters and
that's that's what we're about and when
when was it founded originally
2009 2009
and how did how did the Nate how did you
decide on soul pancake or headed the
team decide on soul pancake is the name
and what were some of the names you
decided against yeah well one of the one
of the really difficult topics that we
were gonna try and bring up at soul
pancake which is the hardest topic in
the world to bring up these days and
that is spirituality so we wanted
something that dealt with spirit it's
not a spirituality site that's just one
of the many things that we talk about
but if you're gonna talk about the human
experience that's part of the human
experience so we wanted something that
had a little bit of a tip of the hat
towards spirituality so we we literally
were like on one of those sites review
you know GoDaddy or one of those sites
where you look up website names right
had food food items written on the wall
and little 3x5 cards and and then other
catchy spiritual and philosophical
minded phrases so we had like holy taco
in a spirit burrito and okay all these
crazy names we were tossing and funny
story I tell this in the book that I
wrote this was actually in handy
grammars apartment Andy Grammer is a big
pop star nowadays back then he was a
struggling street musician so I like to
think that maybe we helped him out by
having this discussion in his house but
then so a soul pancake was just it
wasn't taken so we're like hey that's
perfect
it was crazy what was taken like who
registers the domain name spirit taco
you know right somebody in Montenegro
he's just sitting on that waiting for
the big bid and the a lot of people know
of kid president and that that video and
then the sequence of videos was was that
did that originate on the soul pancake
yeah um not exactly we were having a
discussion early on when we started our
YouTube channel and Devon gondry a
co-founder of soul pancake was talking
you know we really need more joy on our
Channel part of what we try and do at
SoulPancake as we try and be of service
so we're a for-profit company but we're
also trying to be a service to the world
it's a it's kind of a crazy mission just
it's an experiment we're just seeing
what happens so we were looking for joy
on the Internet
that's a hard thing to find absolute joy
not like funny lol's with cats on pianos
and stuff like that but actual joy and
Bobby Miller our channel manager said
hey have you seen this kid kid president
he only had like two or three videos out
at the time they'd only had like 5,000
views and he was in Tennessee a little
african-american kid in a suit in a fake
Oval Office made out of cardboard and
him and his brother-in-law
Brad Montague is a brilliant filmmaker
had done these little videos and we're
like let's bring him over so we just
contacted him and said come over to the
pancake family and a few videos later
when we had kind of given him a little
bit more of a budget and some some
better writing and some inspiration they
came up with kid president's pep talk
which has like 15 million video views at
this point yeah it's incredible
it's it's incredibly bit can incredibly
well excuse me I guess across
SoulPancake you have well over two
hundred million views at this point that
may not be up to date but that's that's
the best number I could find what would
you like just what would you like to see
for for its future well we we want to be
SoulPancake wants to be kind of for lack
of a better phrase I know this is gonna
make some people cringe
I always drives me crazy but I'm gonna
say it I'm gonna go there Tim Ferriss go
for it and that is we're gonna be we
want to be like The Oprah Winfrey for
Millennials we want to be the place that
the brand that has carved out the niche
of feel-good inspiring uplifting
entertainment that digs into big issues
for young people so we want to own that
space and that's that's our goal as a
media company it's an admirable
I think switching gears just a little
bit of course you mentioned you
mentioned Dwight you're very well known
for for planked light on the office but
you've picked up a very wide range of
different characters and projects what
has been the most challenging that comes
to mind and how did you prepare for it
well that's a good that's a great and
deep question so you're getting into the
tasks in the craft of acting a lot of
acting is just like just stand there and
listen and respond and be yourself and
it's not that hard sometimes acting is
hard there's certain roles that are
super challenging I did a movie about
four years ago called Hesher with Joseph
gordon-levitt and Natalie Portman in
which I played a dad a dramatic role of
add a pill-popping dad whose wife had
just died a few months earlier just kind
of stuck in his grief and that was
really challenging because I had to
bring you had to really bring it you
can't fake it you can't fake cry you
can't fake be sad you've got to go to
some really dark places in a movie like
that to to make it believable and make
it pop so that was a very hard month of
doing that movie and challenging and
yeah so I hope people didn't really see
the film you know they don't really see
a lot of independent films these days
but it's a really terrific film
Metallica does the music for it and it's
uh it's really kind of badass and sad
and profound and funny at the same time
how do you explore a dark character like
that or a Backstrom for that matter and
that's that that's another one which I
think people would not immediately
envision in their mind as a role you
would grab given the amount of comedy
that you've done but when you're when
you're trying to put yourself develop
that character put yourself into a state
that facilitates the character how do
you go about doing that and is it
something that you can slip in
out of or does that put you into a funk
for the entire period that you're doing
the shooting well there have been a few
times when I have kind of just had
myself kind of really entered the
worldview of the characters so the
important thing when you're playing a
character is you've got to see the world
through their eyes if you can really see
the world through the character's eyes
then it doesn't matter what lines you
have or what scenes you have or what
conversations you have or situations
it'll be truthful because you're really
tapped into it so sometimes you I'm not
like all mr. method actor or something
like that but there are certain roles
where you you have to do that you have
to you have to go there um for the
duration of the film or when you're on
set or at least just around when you're
shooting my favorite analogy is there's
this extra acting exercise you do an
acting school called as if so you you
just pretend as if so now my wife wasn't
killed in a brutal car accident and I
wasn't addicted to pills but I can
imagine what that might be like so you
act as if your wife my wife who I love
I've been with for twenty years I
imagine what that would it be like if I
were to lose her and if I were to be on
pill I've certainly been on pills before
I've taken drugs before I know what
that's like
you know I've experienced grief before
I've lost friends - you kind of
cultivate a kind of emotional
imagination there's an emotional
landscape that you try and inhabit and
you just go deeply into your imagination
it's just like pretending I mean it's
basically kids in a sandbox like you're
a pirate and I'm a space alien let's
pretend and ready go and you just do it
on a much much deeper level that's
really all acting is about it part of
the reason I ask is because I wonder
when you when you hear people talk of
say a life imitating art or at imitating
life if learning to go into a very deep
dark maybe depressive character in any
way helps you
get out of dark and depressive periods
in your own life so maybe jumping to to
that side of things are there any
particular low periods in your life or
career that you were able to dig your
way out of it or build yourself back up
out of that you think are illustrative
or important very pivotal in your life
well that's a great question
then I've never been asked before I
think that when I did Backstrom I was
going through a really hard time in life
and it had nothing to do with the office
ending it was just a hard time in life
and that was both challenging and
exhilarating to play a character like
Everett Backstrom for those of you for
those 12 of you who watched the show
thank you and for the rest of you [ __ ]
off can I say [ __ ] off on your podcast
kidding no I let it by everyone
he's a very dark human being he sees the
worst and everybody and he sees only
kind of the corrosive in in reality so
it was it was challenging and helpful at
the same time to be in his world view
especially when I was shooting the pilot
it was it was very hard and to go there
when my life was having a difficult time
but at the same time I I kind of found
it exhilarating and I wish I could
answer it better than that but it's both
what was difficult if you're open to
talking about it what was difficult
about your life at the time I was just
going through some family stuff and
marital stuff and personal stuff that
was that was just really difficult and
then I was flying up to Vancouver
shooting Backstrom and it was it was
just a hard time so it was just a really
challenging time on multiple levels what
do you do when you feel overwhelmed what
you what do you do to improve the
situation um well you know I have a
spiritual faith that I rely on that I
use so I use prayer and meditation as
tools to Center me and bring me back
kind of into reality I also find that
for me like acting as a wonderful escape
because I you get out of your own head
and you get to go into someone else's
head and you know it was like that on
the office - and doing comedy you know
and life was good and life was bad was
something wonderful about coming to
Dwight and I could just put Rainn Wilson
aside and just all of that [ __ ] and
clear it out of my head and out of my
heart and just beat Dwight Schrute and
sometimes it was just just super super
fun to do that so those are some of the
tools acting as a tool prayer and
meditation is a tool I use to kind of
bring myself into the into the world and
your your faith I know I'm going to
Massacre this because I've only read it
and not heard it said but is it Baha'i
is that correct of a high but high oh
there we go thank you hi how are you
doing yeah and now I want to come back
to that but what does your when you
meditate what does that look like and do
you do it on a daily basis what what's
the the format of that yeah I try and
meditate every day there's no format in
the Baha'i faith it's just greatly
encouraged to to meditate when you pray
you're communing with the creator you're
communing with the universe you're
putting stuff out there and when you're
meditating you're listening to the
universe but it's really pretty simple
I get a great deal of benefit if I even
do a 10 minute meditation and out of
that 10 minutes if 4 of the minutes my
mind can be very still and very silent
there's great guided meditations now
there's apps there's all kinds of things
you can do for meditation but for me
it's just about I won't say silencing
the mind because that's impossible so
the mind is those thoughts are always
gonna pop up but those thoughts pop up
you just notice them
by them you let them float in front of
your highs almost like you know one of
those old-fashioned Wall Street ticker
machines and and in and you find a
tremendous amount of peace serenity and
bliss in just being in consciousness and
consciousness is not thought
consciousness is just being I am this
being I am NOT separate from the giant
being of Earth and the cosmos in the
universe and just being in that
stillness is incredibly rewarding I get
up I get really a ton of clarity and I
get a ton of energy from it and these
have been proven in scientific studies
by the way in all kinds of things from
healing trauma to giving you more energy
to giving you more focus in your work
it's meditation is a pretty incredible
tool and lowering cortisol I've been
spending time interacting with some
researchers at Johns Hopkins gentleman
named Roland Griffiths and also Jame
Adam ghazali runs a neuro imaging lab at
UCSF and with what's been very
interesting and we don't have to go down
the rabbit hole with this but it appears
that when you if you look at experienced
meditators and brain activity and I'm
blanking on the particular area I think
it might be the somewhere in the
parietal lobe but I could be off in any
case there's a there's a portion of the
brain that is thought to contribute to
the separation of self and other
so it's associated with let's just call
it the ego and that is inhibited both in
the use of say psilocybin which was
found in magic mushrooms but also you
experience a similar type of pattern in
experienced meditators which is kind of
cool and well I know that they oh sorry
gone oh go ahead
yeah I know I heard a fascinating thing
on the radio once where they did a study
and they found the happiest man in the
world so they did a brain scan and they
found the the happiest person they could
possibly find
and this guy was I think he was an
American but he's living in Wisconsin
but he was a he was a student of Tibetan
Buddhism and at the time when they did
the brain scan which charted out as the
very happiest he was in the process of
meditating and it was a meditation of
kind of universal compassion and so it's
a meditation where you are feeling at
one with everyone and great compassion
for everyone on planet Earth and every
and now all beings on planet Earth not
human animal plant what they're going
through and in so doing that achieved
like the greatest happiness that kind of
goes along with what you're saying no
definitely and it's I mean there is a
sort of you even if you are
self-interested there's a biological
benefit to empathy and compassion and
and I just to reiterate something you
said because I think it's so important
is that you know I try to meditate 20
minutes each morning and like you
mentioned there are apps like calm and
headspace that are very helpful for this
but even if I'm just violently violently
excuse me let me try English again
violently getting punched in the psyche
by like my to-do list and worries and
anxieties and thoughts for 15 or even 18
minutes out of 20 if I have two minutes
where the the mud kind of settles and
the the mine is clear it has an
incredible impact on the entire day for
me and I feel exactly the same way
that's exactly my experience even out of
a 10 minute meditation if I can just get
two or three minutes in there where I
have almost achieved thoughtlessness and
just kind of a serene bliss it's it's
like getting it's like taking a power
nap you know and it helps you through
your whole day definitely and I had I
think it was Tara Brock who said this to
me but it might've been someone else but
they said the the if you just come back
to your breath or a mantra or whatever
it is that you're focusing on if you're
doing concentrated meditation it's the
coming back that is the practice so if
you're just distracted and you're
basically just bouncing off the walls
mentally with your monkey mind for those
19 minutes if you come back even once
you can consider it a six
full session I think for type-a
personalities that's really important to
keep them down you mentioned something
I'd love to explore a little bit which
is that acting can be a wonderful escape
and I'm paraphrasing here but from your
own head I was actually watching Amy
yesterday which is a documentary about
Amy Winehouse and very very sad story a
tragic on many levels but she produced
some beautiful music from bad
experiences and she was able to escape
her own head by putting these poems
which became songs on paper are there
any particular exercises from whether
it's acting school or improv or
otherwise that you think could benefit
non actors who just want to help create
new avenues of thinking or embrace some
type of therapeutic effect of getting
outside of their own head yeah you know
um specific ones I suppose I could go
into but I studied with a great teacher
an NYU named Paul Walker he's he died of
AIDS but he was an exquisite teacher and
he taught theatre games and for me that
was a real revelation because I had when
I had tried acting early on I was very
stiff and burying my head and cerebral
and kind of stuck and kind of like it
was very conscious like how am I gonna
say this line and how do i best look
when I'm turning this way it's just a
very self-conscious style of acting that
was bad it was sucking so what Paul got
us doing in acting school at NYU was
just playing and there's something
incredibly freeing about playing like a
kid and that your impulses as an actor
and your impulses as a kid at play are
really the same thing like I said before
it's deeply pretending so you know are
there specific exercises and I suppose I
could think of some but you know how
much fun is it to play red light green
light and for 20 minutes or
duck-duck-goose and then to move from
those exercises into more and more
imaginative kind of
improvisation but where where you allow
yourself to just play like a child and
sometimes children play and they're
competitive sometimes they play in
they're very serious it's not all kind
of this general like we kind of stuff
and I found that so freeing and it was
the it was the key for me as an actor
that kind of broke me open and got me
out of my head and just got me in my
body and in that place of kind of pure
imagination and spontaneity that you
really want as an actor mm-hmm and and I
think it seems to me also when you put
yourself in that place much like
meditation you have to be present state
aware you can't be worrying about
something that you have scheduled two
weeks in the future or yeah resenting
something like you know some idiot who
cut you off in traffic that morning you
have to be in that moment and be
effective and to have fun you just can't
be distracted by those things
yeah like we'll do a thing where you I
just remembered because I did it
recently it's SoulPancake I did some
sessions with the with the employees at
SoulPancake I do kind of games and
improv stuff where everyone is a number
from one to ten there's two teams of ten
on each side of the room there's a stool
in the center of the room with a shoe on
it and the goal is you've got to get the
shoe and then get back to your place in
line right it's pretty simple game but
then you also do this game called sexy
nostril I'll be right down
adjectives and you write down body parts
so it could be angry sad lonely
energetic those are the adjectives and
then body parts you know earlobe
testicle anus shoulder blade you know
fingernail whatever and you draw one of
each and then you try and play a game
manifesting those characteristics if you
have sex nostril and then you have to
play that same game of getting the shoe
and getting back the line but you're a
person where they're center of their
energy is in their nostril and it's a
very sensual sexual energy and you're
just kind of helps you create a
character and play as that character and
it
it takes you out of your head and it
just gets you in your body and gets you
kind of feeling and responding and I
love teaching that stuff it's it's it's
super fun
and for me Tim I'm in my head a lot and
it kind of sucks there's a certain tools
that I have to use to get by so I've
learned in my life I don't remember
every day but there's certain things I
have to do to just be out of my head and
just to get to normal I'm not talking
about like being like really super
effective just to get to normal I have
to do meditation I have to do some
exercise if I if I can get into nature
great if I could play some tennis better
and acting is that same way and acting
rehearsing playing characters these are
the things that get me out of my head
and out of just an app analyzing every
goddamn thing that comes down the pike
and leaves me miserable and making
really bad choices
yeah I'm laughing because I spend so
much time in my own head and when people
are like are you gonna write another
book I'm like well actually I can't
contend with another three years in my
own head right now so no I'm gonna be
putting that off and we're and we're
gonna we're definitely I want to talk
about your book before we get to that I
guess you mentioned exercise you also
mention tennis are there any particular
types of exercise or how do you exercise
what is your your routine your ideal
exercise routine
I'm the worst first of all I'm a big fat
slob so um I'm not I'm not you know I'm
not I don't have the 4-hour workweek in
the 4-hour body down and the four-hour
this I'm like I could do 4 hours of
video games the for our video game diet
I I jog which I love doing because it
also clears my head
and there's something physiologically
you would - I'm sure you know about
about walking and jogging that it
actually is really healing to the brain
because it when you do it the energy
goes back and forth between the both
lobes
the brain so when I was reading about
that I was wondering like why outside
when I go jogging I feel so refreshed
and it's not just the exercise it's also
it's also that physiological component I
play tennis about twice a week I'd love
to play more like three or four times a
week when I'm on 10th when I play tennis
it's all your focus on the ball and the
focus on your movement and these kind of
spiral movements that you're making and
that really gets you out of your head
good and then recently just literally in
the last year or two I've done been
doing some weight training which I find
just I feel really good doing it but
everything I do is super light and
really I'm discipline so please don't
don't let there's not gonna be a Rainn
Wilson though diet and exercise book
coming out anytime soon it's no bad even
talking you about it because you're like
the math you're like the Zen master of
all things exercise well I mean the good
news is it's it's it's very very
minimalist so we could definitely talk
about that another time any time the the
the next few questions I'd like to ask
and I have a feeling that but well bhai
is definitely gonna come back into this
but to to fire off a couple of very
short questions and the answers don't
need to be sure but they can be when you
think of the word successful who is the
first person who comes to mind and why
successful oh man you're killing me um I
don't have anyone coming to mind is that
weird it's not weird we could try we
could try we could try another adjective
maybe what do you think of the word
admirable who's the first person who
comes to mind and why you know when I
think of admirable I do a lot of work in
Haiti and there's a lot of people there
that I've met over the years that have
given up big careers they've given up a
lot of money and a lot of potential in
the United
to go live and work Haiti and just to be
of service to people that don't that
don't have much and to me that's really
admirable there is a woman I'm thinking
of that taught school or whole life in
Haiti and then retired and had a little
bit of retirement money and then she her
name is sue Puzo and she retired and
went to her house and the next morning
there was a ring at her doorbell and
there was a little Haitian boy and he
said hey I heard you used to teach she
said yeah and he's like well I need to
learn how to read we teach how to read
and she's like okay come in let me give
you a little lesson and she gave him a
few little exercises and some sheets to
work on then the next morning he knocks
on the door and there's three little
boys there and he's like I brought two
of my friends we all want to learn how
to read she's like okay come in then the
next day there were more the next day
there were more all of a sudden this
retired schoolteacher who's in her 70s
has created a school in her backyard and
I'm not exaggerating it's all in her
backyard of her house and there's
classrooms there's a tool shed has first
grade and a palm frond has kindergarten
under it and the third graders are on
her deck and in her kitchen are the
fourth graders and she's hired teachers
and she's used her retirement money and
what little inheritance she had to hire
teachers and start a little school and
then she even rented the house next door
to house these homeless Street kids and
I got to see this firsthand many times
and many trips down to Haiti and watch
the evolution of the school eventually
her and her husband just got too sick
and too old to continue it and they had
to transition the kids into other places
but when I think of an admirable like
really admirable you know I know a lot
of billionaires I know a lot of actual
like billionaires and people with a lot
of money I know people I know movie
stars and people that are very
successful in the entertainment industry
nothing against them and a lot of them
are really admirable successful people
but that's what when I think about that
like what really moves me my heart about
you know
what is admirable it's it's selfless
giving to someone else to me is is truly
admirable supuso yeah and you you have
an educational initiative as I
understand it and I'm gonna probably
mispronounce this one too is it ledee a
mile a day you they Huff so close but so
far yeah yeah and if that you Kiki you
could you describe what what the Leda is
is doing in Haiti yeah well my wife and
I went down to Haiti to tour some
schools before the earthquake just a few
months before the earthquake so it was
like six six and a half years ago now
and we fell in love with that country
and I really encourage you all your
listeners to go down to Haiti and give
it a tour and check it out because you
fall in love with the country it's a
beautiful country as ravaged as it is as
poor as it is it's desperate as it is
there's something magical about it it's
um it's it's really the the culture the
arts the music the people the sense of
humor the food the life is really
infectious people really fall in love
with it so we fell in love with it then
the earthquake happened so we started
going down and doing this trauma work
with adolescent girls after the
earthquake where we would use the arts
to kind of heal trauma and then we saw
all these incredible effects of using
the arts with adolescent girls and
education for adolescent girls and
literacy for adolescent girls and then
the more I was reading about it you know
I I read a lot about in the United
Nations recently had a study and you and
you're gonna hear more and more about
this that the number one way to
eradicate poverty in the world is to
educate girls Oh girls I totally a
number one way epic intervene at the
educate if you educate a girl you're
ultimately educating a family and I hate
to say that for the male gender but
there's a lot of like playing craps and
drinking and so on I say girl she she
her children her cousins her aunt's her
mom her sisters and her neighbors if you
educate a boy they moved to the big city
and become an uber driver and that's or
the equivalent that's what always
happens so we got into this arts
education and girls education so we're
out in rural Haiti or way out in the
north of Haiti we go to some really
far-out places that most Haitians don't
even know exist and we do arts and the
self empowerment self-esteem workshops
and literacy and then we give
scholarships and try and get the girls
in the educational system and I will I
will link to you that organization and
the show notes along with everything
else for people who want to to learn
more about it going a little micro I
guess besides the bassoon King what is
the book you've given most to other
people as a gift the book I've given the
most as a gift is called the family
virtues guide by I think it's Linda
Popoff is the last name I think pio pio
vie the family virtues guide is a really
interesting thing I give to parents it
basically talks about virtues based
education and it's for all kids
you could be a theist you can be
Catholic Muslim you can have faith you
can be agnostic whatever one of the
recent developments to in education has
been around you can call it whatever you
like I like calling it virtues but you
can call it character traits or positive
character leadership traits whatever but
teaching a kid that stuff they don't
learn in school about virtues for
instance what are virtues compassion
honesty kindness humility perseverance
determination all of these are positive
virtues you can look at them from a
religious standpoint you can look at
them just from up just a entrepreneurial
you know standpoint but
kids really thrive when they learn these
virtues in the world is really hurting
because the kids don't have them
nowadays they don't learn them in school
and a lot of things they don't learn
them from their parents so family
virtuous guide gives all these exercises
to her we have like a virtue of the week
like we'll have determination as a
virtue of the week and then every day
we'll check in like hey how was your
determination today and my son Walter
was 11 like he'll go like well I was
really having a hard time but then I got
really determined and I I pushed through
and I finished the test and and I feel
really good about myself so it beats so
creating a consciousness about these
character traits is really important
it's a great tool for teachers there's
also a teacher's guide by the same
author and I just think it's a it's a
gold mine that I'm so glad you brought
that up it's very Ben Franklin I I've
been looking for a book like this and
not because I have children but because
I've always wondered why aren't these
traits or characteristics or virtues
like very similar disturber rating in
ancient Greece
why aren't they taught in a progressive
way with exercises because you can you
could ostensibly put something like that
together a curriculum where you have
sort of comfort challenges and exercises
that develop each of these or test each
of these and I feel like I feel like the
family virtues guide is just the
beginning I think you could go way
farther then it goes and I think you're
right there could be an entire
curriculum based around this stuff but
what I what is incredible is when you
bring your consciousness to it like what
happens when you bring your
consciousness to compassion and it you
have a child an eight-year-old or even a
teenager noticing compassion around them
and then noticing when they're
compassionate to someone else like you
compassion can be trained like any other
muscle don't do that definitely I mean
completely and I think there's also a
neurological basis for that there would
have to be that I'm gonna think if
you're if you're if you're digging the
groove and the sort of mental record
player for compassion it's going to
become more and more of a reflexive
action or thought pattern at the very
least
now do you have any favorite
documentaries or films um I have tons of
favorite documentaries now you well
you're really you stumped people with
the questions cuz they're so goddamn you
they're highly specific we could come
back to this one too okay let's come
back to that let me let me move that
okay so we'll come back to the
documentaries another highly specific
one what purchase it doesn't have to be
a purchase but it could be something
free but what purchase of a hundred
dollars or less has most positively
impacted your life in recent memory okay
this it's not a hundred dollars or less
but I have to talk about it let's do it
okay so I was snoring and I was driving
my wife crazy and I was customer more
and more as I was getting in through my
40s and so I went in and then I got this
mouth guard from my dentist that not
only stops me from grinding my teeth but
it kind of moves my jaw forward look
like just by half an interesting like
that when I sleep so it clears like this
air channel mm-hmm and like all of a
sudden like I'm breathing better all
night long and not snoring and I'm
getting like a way better night's sleep
and it's completely transformed my life
and it's so funny that it's just this
little plastic mold you know you put
that your teeth in the mold and they I
wear that in my in my in my sleep and it
is just it's literally changed my life a
piece of plastic and my mouth has
changed my life I love it and that's
something people can experiment with
also if they don't wanna go to the
dentist I mean as someone who's warned
way too many mouth guards because I had
a habit of enjoying getting punched in
the head or kicked in the face doing
combat sports which I don't recommend
for anyone who wants to preserve
cognitive function you can just give
something at a sporting goods store and
I guess the plus is if you're sleeping
in there and you have a home intruder
you also have sort of home game
advantage place what is something that
you can I kick can I kick you in the
face or the head
I tell you what I'll start doing neck
exercises you can start working on your
hamstring flexibility and then I'm happy
to let you give it a go all right boom
we're on oh this is good we can put it
on Soul pancake that that could be very
inspiring Rainn Wilson kicks Tim Ferriss
in the face 15-second video viral it's
it's gonna be used on vine it's very a
very multi-purpose
I what what is something that you
believe that other people think is
insane if anything I've got plenty for
myself but I'm curious if anything I
have so I have so many things that I
believe that people think are just
insane
I believe that world peace is possible I
really do
I believe that you know some things are
gonna have to change where it's not even
close to being there yet but I do
believe that humanity can put its worst
nature aside and find a way to come
together and we see aspects of this more
and more I mean look at the the way the
Western states are acting and
interacting and what had the tragedy in
France and the way the especially the
Western world rallied around France and
you know there's a couple of folks out
there there's a couple of countries that
are some have some big issues and some
big problems but I truly believe that
humanity can do this we can come
together on world peace we can reduce
our armaments to what we need to defend
ourselves and we just work on making a
better world I think that we can get
there I think that it's really easy to
just be negative and like oh that's
[ __ ] never get there knowing people
know where they are and people like
that's such an easy fallback position so
I guess that's something else that I
believe is that cynicism is a disease
that robs people of the gift of life and
it's just it's easy it's way easier to
be negative sarcastic and cynical it's
an easy fallback position and it's much
harder to be hopeful and positive and
proactive all right clearly agree and I
think also that there's a by being
against passive armchair cynicism it
doesn't mean you're
constructive skepticism if that makes
sense a lot of people feel like oh
you're saying I can't be critical it's
like no I want you to be critical but I
want you to be critical in a
constructive way where you're actually
making mistakes of ambition as opposed
to the mistakes of sloth
it's your engine and being critical is
your intention and being critical to
make the world a better place or to
bruton enlightenment then great but if
your intention and being critical is to
bring people down and hold people back
oh my god that'll never work then you
know that's just [ __ ] no I agree one
of the more interesting discussions
about world peace that I've seen was
actually an experimental class at
Stanford with BJ Fogg as part of the
persuasive technology lab and I think it
was peace innovation is what they called
it but what they realized very quickly
they had a class that's full of many
people from of course different genders
different cultures different religions
and they had a lot of trouble on
agreeing upon what World Peace would
look like as a single concept and what
Vijay did which I thought was very smart
he said okay if we're having trouble
agreeing on what world peace exactly
would look like let's agree on some of
the antecedents like what are the
components that would at least have to
be part of something that looks like
world peace and so they started creating
these subcategories and smaller
addressable components of world peace
you don't at the very least I mean
thinking about that scholar smart yeah
would improve things and you might not
get to perfection but you you can at
least improve get the better are there
any common misconceptions about you um I
think the most common misconception of
me is that I'm like Dwight does people
know me as Dwight and they're like they
see me and the airport is like Dwight
it's Dwight are you Dwight and you know
which is a really weird question also
when people say hey are you Dwight
that's like well um I played Dwight but
I can't say I played Dwight because then
I sound like a douche bag like well no I
actually I played Dwight it's actually a
very quite a thing to say
but it's a weird thing to say yes I am
doing cuz I'm not why I'm rain it was
one of like a hundred different
characters that I've played in my life
is Dwight so that's kind of weird so I
think that's a that's a misconception Oh
what do you what do you even as rain uh
what do you have most in common with
Dwight and what do you have what what
what is completely different about the
two of you I guess what I have most in
common is principles
I don't always hold up to them by the
way but I kind of have high principles
about what I should do what people
should do and what's what's right and
what do I have least in common with with
him is I think he's just much more
regimented and authority Vande things in
boxes and straight lines so I don't work
that way I'm quite the opposite and why
did he decide to write a book I had a
story to tell
I knew that I had a lot of funny
anecdotes and there you know most of the
stories of his comedy most of the book
is just I just tried to make it funny
and I think it is very funny it's my own
peculiar look at the world but I also
had a story to tell and that story was
you know when I look back in my life
when I found it SoulPancake and I
actually just happened when I wrote the
introduction of the SoulPancake book
that came out about five years ago I I
realized that you know this spiritual
journey that I've been on which is part
of my journey as a Baha'i a member of
the Baha'i faith is it's really
interesting to me it may not be
interesting to anyone else to me it's
very interesting
growing up in faith losing faith
becoming an atheist and having nothing
to do with God or faith or devotion or
religion or anything like that and then
slowly very slowly over you know a
decade of search going on a spiritual
surge
to find myself to find God my place in
the universe and to me that's a really
interesting through line that runs
through the book so it's 80 90 % comedy
but it has a little bit of this kind of
spiritual quest in it and I think that
we're all on that spiritual quest we're
all like Kwai Chang Caine wandering
around the Old West you know looking for
our identities and and for meaning in
the world and that's okay meaning
doesn't have to be accomplishment in the
traditional Western sense through
accruing crap meaning can come in a lot
of other ways so it helped me find a lot
of meaning and and that's why I wrote
the book so with with you had the soul
pancake book chew on life's big
questions and then now the bassoon King
my life in art faith in idiocy what did
you learn in the process of making the
first book that helped you with the
second book well that was the answer
what I've learned in writing the
introduction to the SoulPancake book was
that oh there's a much larger story to
tell here what I learned in writing the
bassoon King is and I highly suggest
everyone writing a memoir at some point
it's I'm Tim maybe that's your next book
it's just you know a story of life
because people just love stories of
people's lives and their struggles and
their ups and downs and their positive
things but what I learned is like how
many of my greatest failures and tests
have really made me who I am today like
I'll give you a quick example I was cast
in a Broadway show when I was about 29
or 30 years old my first Broadway show
and I sucked I bombed I have a chapter
called I bombed on Broadway I again I
was very in my head I was very stuck and
cerebral and stiff and I couldn't get
out of it and I tried my try but I just
was terrible in the part but after I
finished that show I was kind of like
you know what [ __ ] it I'm never doing
that again
I'm never gonna get stuck in that again
I just I can't
life is too short I'm too miserable and
I gotta be me as an actor I have to
bring who I really am as a as a human to
my acting so it's it's quirky and
offbeat and odd you know I'm a weirdo I
draw I buy shirts at the thrift store
and this is this is who I am and this is
who I have to be so I it really changed
me as an actor and as an artist my and I
went through hell in that Broadway show
but if I haven't gone through that hell
I never would have been able to play
Dwight Schrute I never would have had
the success that I had in LA and on TV
and film in doing odd characters if I
hadn't gone through that terrible
terrible ordeal so that was a critical
thing to learn from writing a book and
looking back at those failures and how
they can be transformative yeah I think
if I ever write a memoir I'll have to do
it soon and it'll be called 14 minutes
into my 15 minutes short biography of
ten short memoir of Tim Ferriss before
it's irrelevant these he one of the the
core tenets of the Baha'i faith because
you it correctly from wrong but your
parents or at least one of your parents
were also behind that right yeah I grew
up Baha'i so the tenants of the by faith
are the highs believe that there is only
one God and that this creator all loving
all-knowing creator wants to educate
humanity by sending down divine teachers
every five hundred or a thousand years
these divine teachers you know a lot of
their names like the Buddha Krishna
Abraham Moses Jesus Mohammed they come
to various people at various points in
time kind of giving an updated lesson in
spiritual evolution from God the Creator
because God wants us to mature
spiritually just like we're maturing
technologically and materially and we're
not there yet so behind that a man named
Mahalo and that name means the glory of
God that baha'u'llah was an axe
person who was lived in Iran in the
mid-1800s he proclaimed himself to be
the Promised One of God the newest the
latest of these divine teachers he was
in a Muslim country so he was persecuted
and locked up in prison and tortured and
banished and his family was killed and
tens of thousands of her liebe highs
were martyred and he's been his whole
life being banished and in prison and he
wrote many hundreds of books and tablets
that I believe are holy and that
contained the solution for the world's
problems today so the highs are hard at
work at kind of healing the world
spiritually theoretically that's what
we're doing and do you have any type of
equivalent or approximation to say the
10 commandments for instance because I
find that if you look at say the Ten
Commandments I mean that a lot of them
seem like pretty good rules or certain
good guidelines even if you are atheist
an atheist or or otherwise and are there
is there a similar sort of to do and not
to do list in the Baha'i faith yeah
there are basic core tenets of the
Baha'i faith so one is the the harmony
of the human race so elimination of
racial prejudice is super important for
the highs we're all one members of one
human family no one is better or worse
from their skin color all religions are
one the essential harmony of I think you
dig this one the essential harmony of
science and religion you know we live in
a world where science and religion are
so at odds and they can't see eye-to-eye
and the secular science folks are like
our religion is [ __ ] and the
born-again fundamentalist religion
people are like Oh scientists are full
of [ __ ] and the highs believe that
they're both manifestations of the
creation of God that science is there
for us to understand the physical world
that were in it's very real religion
without science is mere superstition
according to by Allah one of the
important teachings of the Baha'i faith
is the investment in
visual investigation of truth so every
person is on a journey to find the truth
for themselves and that's an important
obligation for everyone to undertake is
finding the truth for themselves the
Equality of men and women so this was
taught by Baha'u'llah in the mid-1800s
that men and women are equal and a
universal education and another teaching
is the eventual universal language that
if we have a universal language that
runs throughout the world that that will
be you talk about those building blocks
to world peace you know a universal
language that was spoken by everyone on
the planet in addition to whatever their
native language was would be super
helpful so that everyone could
communicate with one another it sounds
kind of simplistic but it actually would
be super super helpful we seem to be
heading that way kind of with English
right now it's kind of becoming a
universal language you go to Europe you
go to China
you've got a rush she'll like everyone
speaks English as a second language so
those are some of the key teachings
there's no clergy in the Baha'i faith
which I really like there's no one above
anyone in the Baha'i faith no one has a
station above anyone else so that's
that's a cool thing and when you pray
what does what does praying look like
give any any favorite or common prayers
and the reason I ask is that again even
for the even for someone who is
non-religious I think there are things
that can be very useful even if they're
just beautiful Asif ease for instance
the serenity prayer is very similar to
the meditations of a lot of stoic
philosophers and I read a lot of stoic
philosophy and I find the serenity
prayer a very helpful thing to memorize
and and consider on a regular occasion
do you have any particular prayers that
you have found helpful over the years or
more most recent yeah I love the
serenity prayer it's it's really it's
really beautiful I love especially the
second half of the serenity prayer which
doesn't get as much focus you're
essentially saying
grant me the courage to do the things I
can mm-hmm so and that's an interesting
way of looking at the world where we
live in a very self-will powered world
like it's like pull yourself up your own
bootstraps and you are what you make
yourself and it's interesting if you if
you believe that there is a creative
force an all-loving all-seeing creative
force that runs throughout the universe
you know that force can be tapped into
you know you can turn to it and you can
ask for help you can ask for courage you
can ask for serenity I think to me the
most important prayers and the ones that
really help balance me out like we
talked earlier on in the conversation
are prayers of gratitude and if I can be
in gratitude every day if I can turn to
the divine presence around me and just
say thank you for my health thank you
for the beautiful sunlight thank you for
enough food in my refrigerator thank you
for keeping my son happy and healthy um
it shifts my day you know and it shifts
my whole perspective cuz I can easily
get like how how come I'm not a movie
star and how come I'm not getting the
work I want to get and you know how come
my books not number one bestseller you
know it's easy to get into that
negativity but prayers of gratitude I
find really helpful and you're coming
back to getting out of your own head I
think that it ties into sort of
compassion and empathy and looking at
the world through a lens other than your
own at the same time I mean I find that
as someone who's hardwired to be to have
type a hard-driving achievement focused
it´ll focusing and driving hard on
something is is not the difficult part
it's stepping outside of that torrent of
self focused thought to exhibit
gratitude an actual appreciation that is
is challenging and that's the piece that
requires more practice which is yeah so
I'm gonna come back and we're gonna wrap
up in just a few minutes but I have I
will come back to the documentary
I've not forgotten but in the meantime
if you could have one billboard anywhere
with anything on it what would it say
maybe it would be a billboard that says
don't be an [ __ ] because that would
make the world a lot better place maybe
someone driving along I'll be like oh
you know what maybe I'm just gonna be
not as much of an [ __ ] today I'm not
gonna cut people off and on the road and
ignore my kids and you know backstab so
I'm gonna work how about that don't be
an [ __ ] is there any particular place
you'd put that anywhere in Los Angeles
what advice would you give to your 30
year old self and if you could just
place us in time or in I guess in in
place and where were you what were you
doing at 30 and what advice would you
give yourself so at 30 I was starving
New York theater actor just kind of
going around trying to get acting work
and you know barely making 17 grand a
year doing theater I did a bunch of side
jobs I was a man with a van I had a
moving company I think that what I would
talk to myself about is you have to
believe in your capacity you have to
believe that your capacity is greater
than you could probably imagine what it
is to me this is a kind of a divine
question God has given us talents and
faculties and it's up to us to discover
them and expand them to their maximum
and use them for maximum service in the
world so I had a lot more capacity at 30
than I thought
I thought of myself is like well you
know I could be I could get some acting
work and maybe I could do an occasional
guest spot in law and order and and make
enough money to just get by as an actor
so I don't have to drive this damn
moving van that was like the extent of
where my imagination was for my
and so I would just say you know believe
in yourself deeper you're you're bigger
you're bigger than that dream dream
bigger I would say dream bigger
that's another that could be your second
billboard after don't be an [ __ ] you
should have primed the pump with that
and then a mile later on sunset you have
a dream bigger just so you're just so
their dreams aren't of being a bigger
[ __ ] yeah favorite documentaries or
films and oh man there's so many
different documentaries I've seen
thousands of them just like just going
there is one that you love just okay you
recommend after the act of killing did
you see that's so good and so brutal a
whole like yeah I mean nothing goes to
the heart of the human condition and the
violence of human beings like that
documentary that's where Indian set in
Indonesia and they go to all of these
men that killed thousands or tens of
thousands of people in a rebellion in
Indonesia and have them reenact how they
killed people and make it into it like
an act shouldn't movie I actually try
and make sections into an action movie
just to see what happens is this kind of
grand social experiment and it's it
really goes into the dark side the
shadow side of the human condition in a
in a way that is so it's hard stopping
and I really like dark stuff a lot and I
would say my favorite movie of all time
is Apocalypse Now and every time I've
seen Apocalypse Now it I see the world a
little bit differently and again I think
you learn a lot about the positive side
of the world by kind of studying the
dark side and again it goes into that
into the very worst of humanity and in
war and in so doing I always find it
really inspiring and kind of I come out
of watching Apocalypse Now like uplifted
you know I don't know maybe that's just
me no it's not just you I had the most
decorated Special Operations commander
during the entire Iraq conflict Navy
SEAL commander named Jaco will link on
the podcast and he said effectively the
exact same thing so it's it's
fascinating to see how
it can span from military to
entertainment but when you're when
you're thinking about the human
condition I mean you do need to consider
the entire picture and not be like the
blind men touching the elephant what is
an elephant ones touching the trunk when
it's touching the tail once touching the
foot and you really have to take in the
macro picture if you want to have a
positive impact and understand what
you're trying to navigate I think in
some capacity
do you have any ask or request for my
audience this is effectively the last
question and then we'll get into where
people can find more about you and so on
but given you asked a request for the
people listening well you know buy my
book buy my [ __ ] book is that
possible to say no that's that's totally
fair well we'll get us I'll ask for a
second request or ask in the book by the
way folks I need the bassoon Kings
hilarious a lot of laugh out loud
moments it's a it's a very fast it's an
easy read and very very honest so if
this is what what your appetite then you
should check it out and I'll link to
that in the show notes as well for
people but any other ask or request yeah
you know I would I would ask people I
would ask listeners I don't want to
sound like pretentious [ __ ] but I
would ask people to dig deeper we can
make the world a better place um we can
ask more of ourselves we can do more for
others and I think that the our life is
a journey and and to dig deep on your
journey and the world will benefit from
it I love it and you said this already
but the advice to your 30 year old self
I think everybody could take it which is
believing that you have more capacity
than you might think and dreaming bigger
it's just yeah that's been so incredibly
useful in my life and I went back I'm
just like wow I cannot believe I was
driving at first gear for so long
yeah the hell was I doing that's a great
way of looking at it yeah where can
people find you online and where would
you like them to go online also well
they can find me at at Rainn Wilson on
Twitter and Instagram on Facebook of
course all that nonsense they can check
out SoulPancake subscribe to our YouTube
channel and check out Li day Haiti work
and check out the incredible work that
is happening in the fields of girls
education arts education and what's also
called informal education where it's
like education under a tree that's the
future and if you want to help change
the world it's through education I
believe that is empowers people to make
the change in their own communities so
check that [ __ ] out a hundred percent
yep if you want to not only help break
cycles of poverty but create problem
solvers instead of problem creators or
passive participants in the world then
education is the the force multiplier
will reign and for those people who are
going to try to find you on the social
webs reign with two N's
it's been so nice to chat with you and
thanks for thanks for taking the time
this has been a blast
you're great at this and you need your
own show but after I kick you in the
face well you know what this is I've
never I haven't said this in a long time
actually I've never said this to my kid
that makes me sound like even weirder
than I am but I'm looking forward to
hanging out and getting kicked in the
face perfect and I may insist I get veto
power on the footwear but besides that I
think we're in good thanks for that and
and Thanksgiving as you said being
grateful should come not just once a
year and thank you for that reminder
rain everybody listening you can find
show notes links to everything all sorts
of goodies that came from this
conversation at 4-hour workweek comm and
click on podcast I'll spell that or just
go to four hour work week comm forts
Podcast and until next time thank you
for listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday if that
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront is a massively
disruptive in a good way set it and
forget it investing service led by
technologists from places like Apple and
world-famous investors it has exploded
in popularity in the last two years and
they now have more than two and a half
billion dollars under management in fact
some of my very good friends investors
in Silicon Valley have millions of their
own money in wealth front so the
question is why why is it so popular why
is it unique because you can get
services previously reserved for the
ultra wealthy but only pay pennies on
the dollar for them and this is because
they use smarter software instead of
retail locations bloated sales teams etc
and I'll come back to that in a second I
suggest you check out wealthfront com
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to
five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they put you
in and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it and here's
the value of wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally art great investing
is a marathon not a sprint and little
things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
dot-com forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of now I do have to read a
mandatory disclaimer wealthfront
Inc is an SEC registered investment
advisor investing in securities involves
risks and there is the possibility of
losing money past performance is no
guarantee of future results please visit
wealth front comm to read their full
disclosure so check it out guys this is
one of the hottest most innovative
companies coming out of Silicon Valley
and they're killing it they've become
massively popular just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront comm forward slash
Tim
this episode is brought to you by me
undies if I'm not going commando I'm in
the undies I have been testing these
underwear for three to four months now
pretty much every day and in fact
throughout a bunch of my other underwear
this morning and on the road in the
house they are extremely comfortable
they look good feel good they are made
of micro Modell 2 times softer than
cotton as scientifically tested using
the kalibata method sounds very fancy of
course and I get a lot of compliments
from the ladies for these you don't get
diaper but you don't get the tired
elastic band they look great and they
have underwear for both men and women
checkout my undies com forward slash Tim
and you can see everything I've been
wearing they're ridiculous the sublime
everything between including my favorite
which is called out and I would be
remiss if I didn't mention there lounge
pants this is a new thing and I've been
wearing their lounge pants when I record
podcasts I've been wearing them out and
about when I'm walking the dog meeting
people for coffee and they are extremely
comfortable they're made from the same
material as the underwear but some of
them like the blue ones I have have
pockets so you can walk about without
seeming like you're off of your meds and
completely crazy
so that is awesome and if you're not
happy with the first pair you try on I
assume that refers to the underwear
they'll refund you completely and you
can keep the peri try it on for free but
if you're that kind of person you should
be ashamed because that's disgusting
me Andy's Campos wash Tim check it out
and until next time thank you for
listening